[Music]
you all excited big wisconsin primary
huh
i actually i tricked three people into
being happy about that
three people like yeah
the primary number 88
in that state i don't care about no
uh yeah there's a little bit of a
controversy going on with wisconsin
primary wisconsin democrats are accusing
mitt romney of handing out free
sub sandwiches in exchange for votes
yeah which explains why today newt
gingrich voted for mitt romney
seven times
he kept going back
i hate him
big mega millions controversy you've all
heard about this in maryland a
mcdonald's employee who won the mega
millions is fighting with co-workers who
claim the ticket was bought in an office
pool
yeah
you know the mcdonald's it's the one
with the sign up front that says home of
the golden arches and that [ __ ] maureen
this is uh interesting the miss universe
pageant reversed its decision
and will now let a transgendered
contestant participate
yeah the uh contestant was so excited to
hear this she could barely hide her
erection
[Applause]
now you know you're not at the voice
that's confirmation
goldman sachs sold their shares in the
new york paper village voice because
it's back page has ads for prostitution
so goldman sachs sold yeah goldman sachs
said the only people that you'd pay to
get screwed are their clients
hey the tony awards announced that neil
patrick harris will host for a third
time
wow can i host the tonys
so once again they've snubbed mike ditka
and he likes that oh i love that joke
any chance to mention duck coach
you know all this the the man on the
quaker oats logo
has gotten a complete makeover including
leaner face broader shoulders and better
hair
yeah he also has a new life partner
uncle ben
[Applause]
hey
i don't know what that means
a new study claims that 4 out of 10
americans are now obese
yeah
the the study was conducted by anyone
working at a water park
hey check this out scientists
scientists now believe that humans
discovered fire one million years ago
the evidence was found on larry king's
first birthday cake
[Applause]
there's no current that's why i'm not
drifting